doctors delivered the Grim health update
that for Tom quote there is no further
hope and recommended his family make an
end-of-life decision Tom has been in
critical condition and in a coma for 10
days after suffering a brain aneurysm
from a stroke inside his La home the 61
year old was last spotted out January
20th at an LA movie premiere what are we
doing today we're blowing up a whole
bunch of stuff Aloha Tom is best known
for his roles in Blockbusters like Pearl
Harbor Black Hawk Down and Saving
Private Ryan Private Ryan was not
necessarily fun it was very satisfying
in 2000 E.T was on set for his action
film red planet here we are in Australia
I'm Tom Sizemore
but Tom's career also has been plagued
by Scandal I have to remember she said
and she said she didn't believe in it
thank the Lord in 2003 Tom was convicted
of domestic violence stemming from his
relationship with famed Hollywood Madam
Heidi Fleiss we're smoothing out some
rough edges like always Tom is also
battled in addiction with cocaine heroin
and meth We're Not Kids anymore this
drug addictions are going to kill us in
2010 he appeared with flights on VH1's
Celebrity Rehab with Dr Drew I care
about you I'm sorry I messed things up
come on meanwhile we have a promising
health update on Jeremy Renner two
months after he was run over by his
seven-ton snow plow
doing quote whatever it takes to recover
the Hawkeye star is seen peddling a
stationary bite his left leg getting
assisted with the strap he also shared
his mental recovery showing fans his
current read the book of Awakening the
52 year old still has a long road ahead
he suffered 30 plus broken bones blunt
chest trauma and Orthopedic injuries as
a result of the accident but he's
getting support from his Marvel co-stars
I talked to him yesterday yeah yeah yeah
yeah he's he's doing all right he's
doing he's doing well he's the best best
guy and you know
um he's awesome
thank you